hey guys Pete here wanted to put
together a video today based on some
comments I've gotten recently also I had
this experience the other day that
brought the first part to mine so a new
video is born speaking of new the new
book giveaway is officially underway so
stick around to the end of the video to
learn more about that as far as spoilers
it will deal a lot with the overall
story but not so much on specific
current events some spoilers if you're
in between seasons 5 & 6 of watching
this show but nothing that will ruin the
show or books for you otherwise so with
that out of the way let's get right into
it on the John ray golf video I put out
yesterday I had a couple comments about
how people hope John wouldn't ride a
dragon under any circumstance because
they felt it would be cheesy that
somehow this great exciting story would
end up being nothing more than a fairy
tale or worse a cliche even though I
couldn't disagree more I get it dragons
are the stuff of kids stories that only
people who are full-blown Renaissance
Faire junkies think are cool not that
there's anything wrong with the
Renaissance Fairs and fantasy in general
but I think we can agree that those
things only represent a small percentage
of popular culture
my experience with Game of Thrones and
then later with reading the books was
this I had but hadn't been watching a
lot of TV shows one season one came out
but inevitably started to hear more and
more people talking about it sometimes
during season two a lot of people were
starting to get hooked so I asked
someone about it I can't remember
precisely if they mentioned it had
dragons or dragon eggs in it because the
word dragon was enough I was like oh
cool it's got dragons that's not
something I would like bring this up
because I was reminded about it two
nights ago right now I'm in a country
that's about 9,000 miles away from where
I grew up different in a lot of ways
especially culturally I met up with a
local guy who grew up here who's a Game
of Thrones fan and when we were out and
about talking about the show he
mentioned that he had the exact same
experience he had heard the show had
dragons and wasn't interested so the
moral of the story is that the relative
on coolness of flying magical beasts
crosses multiple cultures now obviously
I've evolved on the subject
after all I'm making my second
dragon-related video in as many days I
started watching the show realized it
was a good story and eventually became
hooked as soon as Ned lost his head in
the beginning when I told people about
the show I actually even say things like
it has some magic and stuff but it
doesn't take away from the show here's
the thing though dragons in general may
be the things of children's stories they
may even be the spirit animal of the
biggest weirdo you've ever met but take
a step back and think about the role
they play in this completely made-up
world we all casually talked about in
the comments like it's real besides the
men and everything else that inhabits
this world one of the forces of nature
that shaped it are the Dragons the
Valyrian freehold is the mightiest
Empire Empire that planet OSes that
likely ever known they were far more
technologically advanced than their
neighbors and basically held on to their
power through their dragons now despite
being so advanced they weren't the
greatest people they had the super
weapon and they used it to enslave other
civilizations to the dirty to do their
dirty work of mining for them eventually
the doom came and wiped them all out
except for one Dragon Lord family who
got the idea from a dream the close up
shop and clip moved closer to Westeros
this of course was the Targaryen family
who used their dragons to conquer the
entirety of their new home it didn't
happen overnight but they used their
super weapon to roll over all the long
existing kingdoms that made up Westeros
so you see what the Dragons are their
weapons and their effective ones that
there isn't a great counter for like
think about Cersei super weapon the
mountain not much use against a dragon
or three in fact that Targaryen only had
problems when they started fighting
against each other their Dragons didn't
die off until the dance and they didn't
lose the iron throne until about 150
years after they lost their dragons
would there have been a successful
rebellion if they still had them
probably not anyways in my war for the
dawn video I laid out my thinking in
relation to another supernatural force
in this world that's advancing towards
humanity the White Walkers who raised
the dead to fight for them are headed in
man's direction and by man
mankind they haven't done anything like
this for about eight thousand years and
back then it was pretty devastating to
put it into perspective on how a special
weapon might be needed just think about
brands direwolf summer bravely summer
sacrificed himself to slow the weights
down and it didn't work at all like he
didn't even hold them up or buy them
five extra seconds so if you're really
hoping to see john fighting alongside
goes taking out the white walkers one by
one be careful what you wish for the
dragons on the other hand are weapons of
mass destruction and one that our pals
are going to need before the series ends
if it's any consolation at least the
breaker of chains and the guy who only
ever wanted to be accepted into the
family he that raised him are the ones
who are closest to this powerful weapon
right now I mean it could be worse what
if little finger had dragons or Europe
that's not how the story is set up
though and that's why Game of Thrones
dragons are actually cool and not cheesy
at all in the past people who used them
as a weapon for personal gain or to
suppress other people eventually felt
here they actually serve a purpose and
in that sense they make the story better
when you look at the big picture so I'm
not saying that the you know the world
for the dawn or and you know nothing
surprising is gonna happen there but
it's going to happen and whether the
Dragons open the door for a diplomatic
solution or they're just a powerful
weapon that destroys the White Walkers
one way or another they're essential to
even the score the other thing I wanted
to address in this video is a question
comment I got over and over again it's
the idea that bran will use his warding
abilities to skin change one of the
remaining dragons thus becoming like the
third head of the Dragon comes from the
idea that the three-eyed Raven told him
that he wouldn't be able to walk again
but he would fly I've never been a fan
of this theory for several reasons and
so I'm biased about it for sure it's not
outside the realm of possibilities but
there are a lot of strong arguments
against it personally I believe that
when the Bloodraven said that what he
was that bran would be able to leave
where he was under the tree and fly by
looking through the weirwoods of course
he can also skin change ravens and stuff
like that but I don't think that's what
he meant
the simplest example I can think of to
explain why is that he says you won't
walk when Brandt enters summer or Hodor
he does actually walk so even though he
can fly through Ravens it just doesn't
make sense that this was the meaning
behind what he said for me this means he
didn't say it to give us a clue that
Brandi would eventually take over one of
the Dragons I could be wrong here and I
wouldn't be totally upset if the story
works but that's just how I feel about
it there's also the whole vert Muir
story in the costuming from his mentor
Hagin about taking over people when Vera
Muir tries to do it it doesn't end well
which makes me believe something similar
would probably happen with a dragon plus
on top of that there's no history of a
person ever skin changing a dragon that
in any of the stories as far as that
third dragon is concerned that's another
video altogether like dragon video
number five from a person that was
skeptical about ever starting to watch
the show because they were involved in
the first place anyways that's what I
think about the brand we'll work a
dragon theory flame away in the comments
if you like but also leave a comment if
you agree please like the video if you
enjoyed it and don't forget to subscribe
to become eligible for the new giveaway
also follow me on my social media
accounts you can find the links in the
video description or on my channel page
and I'm always on Twitter when I'm not
on YouTube about the giveaway when I hit
28,000 subscribers I will get one lucky
commenting fan a copy of the great
looking 20th anniversary edition of Game
of Thrones all you have to do to enter
is be a subscriber and comment on any or
all of the videos where I mentioned the
giveaway for more info on how it works
you can check out my Dragonstone video
to see how the winner was selected in
the first giveaway thanks for watching
I'll talk to you soon